Traduttore: Andrea Busetto
Revisore: Luisa Lualdi
E quindi cominciano da lontano, dal 2245:
l’Enterprise, chi non la ricorda?
Spero anche i più giovani...
dove una cosa veramente straordinaria
e che ci colpiva da bambini, e da grandi,
era il teletrasporto.
E quando ho cominciato ad avvicinarmi
alla stampa 3D
caso vuole che in quegli anni,
nel 2014 in particolare,
ha cominciato a interessarmi
la stazione orbitante.
Quella di prima
era un falso della letteratura
meravigliosa, cinematografica,
questo è un vero,
questa è la
Stazione orbitante internazionale.
Su quella stazione orbitante,
non tutti lo sanno e ve lo dico io,
c’è una stampante 3D.
E su quella stazione orbitante,
nel 2014 dell’epoca nostra,
è successa una cosa straordinaria:
che Samantha Cristoforetti
e il suo equipaggio
e Butch Wilmore che era il comandante
hanno chiesto alla base una cosa
perché avevano bisogno di un oggetto,
avevano bisogno di un cricchetto,
di una chiave.
Hanno mandato questo messaggio, appunto,
e dalla NASA gli hanno mandato questo...
e non l’hanno mandato soltanto a loro,
l’hanno mandato postandolo
sul sito di www.nasa.org
dove tutti potete trovarlo...
il file cosiddetto STL
che consente di stampare questo.
E noi e un po’ di milioni di altre persone
abbiamo cominciato a stamparlo.
Perché? Mah, intanto perché è bello...
è bello sapere
che hai un oggetto che funziona,
è stampato - per i tecnici -
in un pezzo solo,
non c’è assemblaggio qua.
Dentro c’è una signora frizione
che per spiegare magari a qualcuno
come funziona una frizione,
vederla mentre cresce
dentro la stampante, ha un significato.
E noi insieme ad alcuni milioni di altri
ce lo siamo stampato
e adesso ce l’ho qui e mi chiedo
“cos’è straordinario e cos’è quotidiano?”
Comincio a chiedermelo ora:
io posso stamparmelo tutti i giorni
se voglio sperimentare
la potenza di questo concetto,
però, certo, è stata la prima volta
che è stata - come dire -
realizzata una stampa 3D
on demand nello spazio...
la cosa più vicina al teletrasporto
che io possa proporvi oggi.
Eccolo qua... ed eccolo qua soprattutto.
Poi, a questo punto, ho pensato
di spostare la vostra attenzione
sul titolo, appunto del, mio intervento
che è "Fare o non fare, non esiste provare"...
Ricorderete, anche questa
è una citazione piuttosto colta:
il maestro Yoda... che spero ci perdonerà
per quest’uso un po’ ingegneristico
che ora cominciamo a fare,
e ci concentriamo sul “fare”.
Allora andiamo a vedere
cosa dice il vocabolario Treccani
o il Cambridge Dictionary
quando si parla di fare.
Dice che fare ha tanti significati,
ma ce n’è uno - quello lì, lì davanti -
che mi piace
perché ha a che fare con il costruire,
il fabbricare, il mettere insieme.
Pensate la Treccani addirittura
per dare il senso di quel fare cita Dante:
"Colui lo cui saver
tutto trascende fece li cieli"
non è che se li è inventati,
li ha fatti, pure Lui.
E lo stesso nell’inglese...
l’inglese ha un vantaggio,
noi di fare ne abbiamo uno solo,
loro hanno il meraviglioso verbo "make",
che nell’inglese quindi
noi abbiamo tradotto "make or make not",
perché è il "make", non il "do",
che attiene al produrre,
ed è quel "make"
che a me interessa sottoporvi.
Perché vedete, io credo in questi…
sono vecchia,
e appunto è 35 anni che sto qua,
e ne ho viste un po’ di tutti i colori,
quando io ero piccola
non c’era che due canali,
il terzo è arrivato dopo,
e il telefono stava alla parete,
non in tasca.
E io allora sono cresciuta in un contesto
dove il fare aveva un profondo significato,
ho fatto ingegneria
perché volevo fare le cose.
Non posso negare
che negli ultimi 15, 20 [anni]
un certo distacco dal fare
nel senso di costruire,
a causa della meravigliosa potenza
dell’usare strumenti che sono potentissimi,
che ci fanno connettere,
che ora ci guardano in streaming...
che meraviglia...
però se li apriamo, uno di quelli,
dentro, non sappiamo cosa fare.
Allora io dico, facciamo cose,
nel senso di "make",
e cerchiamo di farle
in un contesto che sia di ricerca.
Quindi io 5 anni fa ho iniziato a
dirottare dallo studio solo delle molecole
meravigliose, i polimeri
- io studio la plastica -
a qualcosa che avesse
un’implicazione più immediata;
ci sono 3 date che vi propongo,
sempre in questo passaggio temporale
che è partito dal futuro e ora torna al passato,
in bianco e nero le foto del passato,
volutamente.
In quel laboratorio il professor Natta
conduceva i suoi studi di chimica analitica
e con i suoi collaboratori
prese il premio Nobel
per la scoperta
del polipropilene isotattico,
unico premio Nobel per la Chimica
di questo Paese.
Poi invece nel 1986, meno famoso per i più,
Chuck Hull,
questo signore un po’ attempato,
allora era più giovane,
ma sempre un po’ serioso,
brevetta la prima stampante 3D,
non come quelle che ora vedete nelle case,
un po’ diversa,
ma fa il primo brevetto nell’86
e fa anche un sacco di soldi, beato lui,
perché ha avuto questa idea straordinaria
di far fare le cose in modo rapido,
prototipabile eccetera, con stampanti
- le sue - in genere molto costose.
Brevettatissimo, tutto.
Nel 2011 questo simpatico
signore sulla sinistra
che si chiama Adrian Bowyer si inventa
- in realtà ci aveva cominciato a lavorare
già prima, nel 2004 circa -
questo progetto che si chiama RepRap.
RepRap vuol dire replicare rapidamente,
e quella foto indica
che lui mette a fuoco un concetto:
fare macchine a basso costo
che siano genitori
di altre macchine affini,
quindi la macchina figlia si stampa
con la macchina mamma. Sì, femminile.
E loro diffondono questo sapere.
Perché il 2011?
Perché sono passati 25 anni dall’86,
e nell’86 più 25 scadono i brevetti.
Quindi questo momento per chi lavora
con la stampa 3D è altrettanto epocale.
E allora io decido...
vengo a contatto
grazie a miei allievi di design,
devo dirlo, molto visionari...
vengo a contatto con questa cosa,
del potere
- ci provo almeno, nel quotidiano
o nello straordinario, vediamo -
introdurre stampanti 3D a basso costo:
(la più costosa nel nostro laboratorio,
tranne una che è particolarissima,
la più costosa nel nostro laboratorio
costa 4.000 euro,
ed è grande, fa cose grosse).
Quindi introdurre
strumenti a basso costo
facilmente condivisibili
e intrinsicamente inclusivi.
Cioè ho pensato che
mi pareva interessante fare cose
non per qualcuno soltanto,
come la scienza di base fa,
e Dio la benedica,
ma c’era un altro binario forse,
per fare cose con qualcuno,
includere persone normalmente non dedite
alla ricerca in questo percorso.
Ecco che metto a fuoco una cosa
che poi più tardi,
tipicamente un paio di mesi fa,
sento chiamare come io volevo chiamarla,
la frugal research,
non me la sono inventata io,
negli Stati Uniti sta prendendo piede,
il professor P
sta facendo cose meravigliose,
in cui lui dice:
siccome soldi qua non ce n’è,
cioè loro ce li hanno ma noi meno,
quindi per noi è più vero,
non possiamo tutti permetterci
macchine da 500.000 euro
per fare sognare il mondo...
qualcuno ce le ha ed è bene
che con responsabilità ed etica
lavori bene per diffondere quello che sa.
Poi però vengono fuori macchine,
e non solo le stampanti 3D...
i tagli laser, addirittura strumenti
di caratterizzazione di materiali,
che costano,
che riusciamo a fare costare un po’ meno
con un concetto di frugalità
che è fare tanto e bene con poco.
Ed ecco che arriva il Più Lab,
i lavandini sono gli stessi,
perché il laboratorio dove io
ho l’onore di lavorare con i miei ragazzi
è lo stesso di quello di Giulio Natta
che faceva le analisi chimiche.
E mi trema sempre la voce quando lo dico,
non riesco mai a dirlo tutto filato.
I lavandini non sono più apribili
per questioni di sicurezza,
i banconi sono gli stessi,
dovremmo metterli a posto
per questioni di sicurezza,
e sarà un giorno faticoso.
Comunque, lì abbiamo cominciato
con le stampanti,
e abbiamo cominciato a connettere persone,
perché c’è un fascino, un aspetto ludico,
vi ricordate la prima volta che avete visto
una stampante 3D? Spero di si.
Perché è un bel momento,
tu vedi le cose che si fanno,
è magico, è come il teletrasporto...
e allora abbiamo cominciato a fare cose.
E qui c’è il mio preferito,
che è mio nipote Matteo,
che ebbe secondo me la fortuna,
spero che la consideri tale,
in realtà 3 anni fa (aveva 10 anni)
di vedere una stampante 3D come quella...
e io gli chiesi “Matteo che cosa vuoi fare?
Ti porto a vedere una stampante 3D”,
e lui mi disse: “Voglio fare questo”.
Voi non lo vedete, si vede un po’ meglio
nell’immagine di destra,
è un cubetto di Lego da 1,
e io gli ho detto “Scusa Matteo,
ma perché non fai una barca a vela?
Cioè, è tanta roba quella lì!
E perché poi da 1?”
“E per forza zia, perché i pezzi da 1
sono pregiati, sono preziosi,
perché Andrea me li perde sempre
e quando mi servono non ce li ho".
Lui nega di aver detto
questa frase così, oggi;
più o meno l’ha detta così
e io l’ho fatta mia
ed è il mio slogan
che non riesco a cambiare,
insieme a un altro paio che verranno dopo.
La stampa 3D... quando mi dicono
“Ma professoressa, ma poi alla fine
a che servirà la stampa 3D?”
“Stai sereno, intanto la stampa 3D
serve a fare quel che serve quando serve”.
È un concetto raffinatissimo
di questo bimbetto di 10 anni allora.
Cambiare il punto di vista, fare ordine...
intanto il mondo veniva un po’ invaso
negli anni successivi da nanetti, vasetti,
tutti a fare cose… la stampa 3D…e vabbè.
Per un po’ va bene,
poi bisogna cominciare a fare ordine...
e allora abbiamo cominciato
a razionalizzare questa cosa,
perché uno dovrebbe stampare in 3D?
Per esempio, per copiare.
Per esempio per copiare...
e allora ci siamo messi a copiare
- quotidiano - pezzi di Milano.
Lì vedete la skyline,
questo è il Castello Sforzesco.
Non ha una risoluzione "assoluta",
da architetto,
però ha una risoluzione quotidiana, bella,
e che ci ha consentito di avere un pretesto,
perché questo lo vide a una mostra
un non vedente,
il direttore dell’Istituto dei Ciechi,
che mi propose di portarlo all’Istituto
per far vedere con le mani
Milano a chi non vede.
E questa è un’altra, come dire,
pietra miliare della nostra storia,
per cui è stato facile
entrare in contatto
con persone che con il fare
devono ragionare diversamente da noi.
E così abbiamo cominciato ad esplorare
il personalizzare...
questo è un pezzo di Pirandello
che non riesco a non mettere,
gli altri li ho tolti
per mancanza di tempo:
“la fantasia abbellisce gli oggetti,
cingendoli e quasi irraggiandoli
d’immagini care.
Nell’oggetto amiamo
quel che vi mettiamo di noi.”
È tantissima roba.
Questo cambia il paradigma
dell’usa e getta,
tutti mi dicono: “Uno stampa in 3D
e poi lo butta...”
dipende... da cosa c’ha dentro.
Se lo stampa perché lo vuole,
perché gli serve quando serve,
non lo butterà, e imparerà a ripararlo,
soprattutto se è piccolo.
E quindi abbiamo introdotto questo
meraviglioso concetto del personalizzare
non per qualcuno ma con tutti;
e allora abbiamo cominciato a lavorare
con persone che hanno l’artrite
e hanno difficoltà
ad aprire le bottigliette.
E con loro - non da noi,
che chissà cos’avremmo tirato fuori -
abbiamo iniziato con questo e poi abbiamo
continuato con altre forme, eccole lì,
per risolvere con loro un altro problema,
che voi, se non avete qualcuno con l’artrite
che gli impedisce di opporre il pollice,
non ci avete mica pensato a quanto
è difficile abbassare una cerniera
se non puoi opporre il pollice.
Ti cambia la vita, anche questo.
Perché le ragazze
- è una malattia di genere purtroppo,
4 su 5 sono donne -
avevano già pensato... ferretti, legnetti...
ok stampiamolo con un pernino...
e sono impazzite,
hanno cominciato a farne di tutti i colori,
tutte le forme,
ne abbiamo una collezione,
ognuno faceva il suo, lo pensava,
se erano brave a disegnare
se lo disegnavano da loro,
e sennò ci sono i designer,
che sono straordinari
perché sanno anche mettersi al servizio,
a volte.
E quindi arriviamo a un altro esperimento,
che c’entra con il quotidiano e lo straordinario,
e c’entra con la condivisione
di questo meraviglioso mondo.
Negli USA c’è un ragazzo fantastico,
che si chiama Andreas Bastian
e lui è un grande,
lavora nella fondazione Google...
è quello che fa gli arti a basso costo,
andatelo a vedere Andreas.
E lui aveva pensato di stampare
dei tutori, rettangolari i suoi,
da mettere al polso per fare delle cose,
piani.
Poi noi, con lui, ci siamo accorti che
il polimero di cui è fatto questo oggetto
ha una meravigliosa transizione vetrosa
- così l’ho detto oggi e vado bene -
che ci consente di rammollirlo,
termoformarlo sul braccio della persona.
Quindi questa non è
una polsiera qualsiasi, è la mia,
e ieri sera con Davide
me la sono messa a misura.
Ecco dunque il fare insieme:
fare insieme - sono gli unici due nomi che cito -
e sono Laura, e poi ci sarà Giulia.
Laura l’abbiamo incontrata
al workshop all’Istituto dei Ciechi,
perché Laura dalla nascita
ha una malattia che peggiora
per cui adesso ha uno stato
di ipovedenza molto spinto.
E le ho detto “Laura, ma tu
cosa vorresti fare con queste stampanti?”
Lei è venuta, subito si è entusiasmata,
e la prima cosa che ci ha detto è
“Ma io studio la musica”.
Si, Laura studia pianoforte, batteria,
tira di scherma, fa cose così.
E ha detto “ Io ho lo spartito in Braille,
è pesantissimo, fatemene uno dal nero,
e magari dal file MIDI”.
E così con Stefano, che ci ha fatto
la laurea sopra a Design & Engineering,
abbiamo stampato il primo spartito
da file MIDI su supporto flessibile,
col quale speriamo di andare avanti a,
come dire, diffondere questo sapere.
Ma poi Laura,
che ha una straordinaria sensibilità,
ha cominciato
a frequentare il laboratorio,
ed è venuta a fare
l’alternanza scuola-lavoro da noi.
Per cui Laura ha lavorato coi ragazzi...
qui c’è Valerio che
le insegna a cambiare il filo.
Cambiare il filo è un’operazione importante
in una stampante 3D, cosa che lei ha fatto,
e con lui e con gli altri
lei ha deciso di progettare
modellando con le mani dal Pongo,
dal Lego,
quell’oggetto sulla destra
che è la sua non-libreria,
che risolve un po’ di problemi di spazio
a me e a lei che siamo tanto disordinate.
Qua sotto c’è un video: venne a trovare
Laura durante il suo percorso Vincenzo.
Anche Vincenzo non ci vede e loro due
hanno lavorato per un pomeriggio insieme
e quello che vedete è Laura
che insegna il cambio filo a Vincenzo.
È quotidiano o straordinario?
Io non lo so più...
per me è straordinario,
però a noi capita tutti i giorni.
E poi da cosa nasce cosa - citazione -
e Laura dice:
“Ma... guarda che c’è un problema:
se io voglio fare con i miei amici
- e Vincenzo che fa
l’informatico anche di più - dei grafici"
Loro ormai con il voice-over leggono,
scrivono anche superando il Braille,
ma i grafici sono un problema,
come fai a vedere una curva?
Per esempio y=x,
una bella retta che passa per l’origine
La scrivi l’equazione, ma come la vedi?
Lì ancora oggi alcuni hanno dei punzoni
dove degli operatori tracciano,
con un punzone appunto, il grafico a mano.
E invece, con Christian,
Laura si è messa a lavorare,
e Christian si laureerà
la settimana prossima,
per fare la prima
stampante 3D per grafici tattili.
Quindi lì dentro c’è un punzone
che preleva un file dove c’è quella retta
e fa quello sulla destra.
Ah, si vede! Pensavo che noi vedenti
non avremmo avuto modo di vederlo,
però quello che è
più bello di tutti è questo,
perché questo
potreste vederlo con gli occhi chiusi.
E questo ritengo personalmente
sia un passaggio
che se coi ragazzi riusciamo
a farlo diventare qualcosa di più grande,
magari su scala anche del mercato,
potrà dare delle soddisfazioni a molti,
quotidiane.
Siamo verso la fine, c’è "creare",
dietro qui c’è un video, e…
questo è Moonflower
e questo è il video che racconta
lo sbocciare di un fiore molto particolare
e assume questa meravigliosa forma
in un tempo, diciamo, ragionevolmente breve,
tanto da farci un time-lapse...
E quindi Gabriele ha preso quel film,
ha fatto il time-lapse,
l’ha ridotto in disegni del perimetro,
ha messo quei disegni dei perimetri
che crescono uno sopra l’altro...
e ha fatto questo.
Questo è l’unione dello spazio e del tempo
dello sbocciare di un fiore.
È straordinario o quotidiano?
Secondo me è quotidiano
perché, per esempio,
non è fatto di plastica,
è fatto di ceramica,
perché abbiamo imparato
a lavorare anche la ceramica,
e con noi in Italia - devo dire -
ci sono delle straordinarie realtà
che lavorano la ceramica
e 3 anni fa facevano queste casette
e adesso fanno case
che sono le più alte del mondo,
con una stampante alta 12 metri
che si candida a fare moduli
da portare nei Paesi del Sud del mondo
a bassissimo costo.
E così arriviamo al parallelo
dello straordinario e quotidiano:
Giulia aveva un sogno, lei è in carrozzina
da quando è molto piccola:
di mangiare da sola.
E così ci ha chiesto un braccetto,
si chiama Dandy, che costasse poco,
da poter usare e usare quando voleva...
in realtà lei lo sta muovendo già
con un joystick modificato sulla sua mano.
Ci sarebbero tante cose da dire...
qui la stampa 3D è stata ancillare,
ci ha consentito di usare dei motori
non perfettissimi stampando pezzi, le scocche
e Karim si laurea la settimana prossima
con Giulia, che avrà il suo braccio.
E poi mi fa piacere dire questa cosa,
perché questo secondo me è straordinario,
perché sembra non avere a che fare
con la materia, ma se voi inquadrate quello lì
finite sul sito del nostro laboratorio
e trovate tutti i file STL
dei pezzi che vi ho mostrato
e anche molti di più.
E non importa se non avete una stampante...
venite qui a Design,
avete i FabLab vicino a casa
e se qualcuno ve lo volete stampare,
stasera lo potete fare.
Perché se potete sognarlo, parafrasando
un grandissimo, potete stamparlo.
E allora bisogna essere belli e coraggiosi
e dire con forza il messaggio che vi lascio:
questa è tanta roba, è tanta roba.
È tanta roba e secondo me attiene
a qualcosa che per me è affidare,
dare un'opportunità a chi lavora
con me quotidianamente
che è rivoluzionaria.
La rivoluzione del fare è riprendersi
il fare che abbiamo un po’ perduto,
questo può cambiare tutto nella società,
credetemi.
E il secondo messaggio
che vi lascio, ovviamente
(qui siamo tutti noi alla Maker Faire,
dove siamo andati a condividere
con bambini, famiglie,
110.000 persone in 3 giorni,
queste cose che abbiamo pensato):
non dimentichiamo mai, ma proprio mai,
che fare è di tutti,
come dico io, proprio di tutti.
Non c’è verso:
Fare o non fare,
non esiste provare.
Grazie.